good old Shepard Smith on fox news just
shredded Donald Trump yesterday saying
quite simply Trump is not telling you
the truth
and of course Trump is furious over this
and is now saying it's time for
Republicans and right-wingers to move on
from Fox News to something else I've
been predicting that I'll talk to you
about that a little bit later on today
Donald Trump of course as I told you
earlier on in the show panicking about
the border wall I told you earlier he is
now telling officials break the law do
whatever you need to do start seizing
land start of appropriating funds build
the dam wall and I will pardon you he's
also lying by saying he's building the
wall which is simply not true so in this
clip that I'm going to show you some
excerpts of Shep Smith is doing multiple
fact checks he is one of the few sort of
occasional voices of reason on Fox News
it's no big accomplishment it's no big
praise it's merely listen every once in
a while Shep Smith and sometimes chris
wallace and one time of neil cavuto just
tell the truth on fox news and it's
notable because it's so infrequent that
it takes place here is Shep Smith
starting to just very clearly say what
Donald Trump is telling you is not true
as doriot appears ready to skirt by the
American territory of Puerto Rico if not
hit somewhere around San Juan president
Trump is calling the island one of the
most corrupt places on earth
he added that by the way he's the best
thing that ever happened to Puerto Rico
those clearly are opinions as opposed to
facts so there's something actually
brilliant about this that I want to talk
about Shep Smith is sort of being snarky
by saying this is an opinion and not a
fact like in the ideal world people
would understand that when you look at a
tweet from the president this is the
perspective this is the point of view
this is the opinion of the president
that's it it might contain accuracies it
might contain inaccuracies but it's not
just snark on fox news it's actually
extremely relevant that shepard smith is
saying that's an opinion and not a fact
because this is fox news and we have to
think about the fox news audience and
that this is a fox news anchor
Fox News has made a business out of
blurring the lines between news and
opinion we've talked many times about
this Fox News will often stand behind
this idea that we may have a right-wing
bent on our opinion programs but our
news programming is just news and of
course there is no just news programming
on fox news that is not ideologically
right-wing and they are notorious for
deliberately confusing it's low
information audience about what is a
news report and what is an opinion and
can you tell from the way it looks can
you tell from the language that's being
used how is it that you can tell the
whole point of fox news is they blur the
lines so that their audience can't tell
the difference so to you and me when
Shep Smith says this is an opinion not a
fact we see it as kind of being clever
or snarky or making a joke there are
tons of people in Fox News's audience
that do not understand the difference
between news and opinion and they
believe that everything fox news says is
simply reporting a fact they believe
that everything Donald Trump tweets is a
fact so it's actually very clever of
Shep Smith to point this out because of
the fox news audience audience on any
other channel it would be like yeah we
know that
let's continue the president also
repeating his false claim about the aid
that Puerto Rico has received here's
this tweet from yesterday Wow yet
another big storm heading to Puerto Rico
will it ever end Congress approved 292
billion dollars for Puerto Rico last
year an all-time record of its kind for
anywhere that is decidedly not true we
checked with sources including the
Federal Emergency Management Agency or
FEMA and the latest numbers show that as
of the end of June the federal
government has allocated forty 2.7
billion for Puerto Rico Shep Smith has
to talk like a teacher talks to a
first-grader do you know the difference
between a lie and the truth this is an
example of something that is not true
it's truly amazing that whenever a fox
news host has to stop the disinformation
narratives that they perpetuate suddenly
they have to talk like they're speaking
to a child or I guess to an adult
but severely cognitively or
ideologically limited okay and then on
to the actual part about the wall an
hour ago he tweeted that the wall is
going up very fast despite obstruction
by Democrats and today the Washington
Post reports the president is telling
his aides to use quote eminent domain to
seize private land and ignore
environmental laws and that he told
senior aides that if he doesn't get it
done it would be embarrassing
and when staffers explained that some of
his requests would require them to break
the law the paper reports he responded
that if anybody gets in trouble quote
don't worry I'll pardon you the Post
reports one official told The Washington
Post that the president was joking and
just moments ago the president tweeted
that the report is as he put it fake
news but the president also said in the
tweet that the wall is going up rapidly
it is not as we just reported there is
no new wall once again Shep Smith has to
explain to his viewers as if they are
just little kids in the most basic terms
and the most basic language possible in
some sense I'm kind of imagining being
Fox native Fox near being chef Smith on
Fox News it must be frustrating if
you're Shep Smith to realize that if you
want to communicate truth to your
viewers if you want to puncture the echo
chamber in which your viewers mostly
live you have to do the news equivalent
of baby talk in any case good for Shep
Trump seems to be abandoning Fox News
anyway and maybe his supporters will
wilt as well I want to talk about that
next because this is a story that I
predicted months ago and it's continuing
to grow